welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Genevieve LeBaron a senior lecturer
in politics at the University of
Sheffield in the UK and human
trafficking and modern day slavery
fellow at the Gilder Lehrman Center for
the Study of slavery resistance and
abolition at the Macmillan Center she's
the author of protest Inc the
corporatization of activism with Peter
Davern as well as numerous journal
articles she also writes widely for the
media and is founder and editor of the
beyond trafficking and slavery section
of open democracy net which has over
nine million readers last year she was
awarded the British Academy for the
humanities and Social Sciences
rising star engagement award today we'll
talk with her about global labor
standards and exploitation
welcome professor LeBaron thank you for
having very nice to have you here with
us today so let's start with a kind of
an overview of the book project you're
working on tell us about it
sure the book project that I'm working
on here in my fellowship at Yale is
looking at what the big brand companies
are doing about forced labor human
trafficking and slavery in their supply
chains so that's looking at companies
like Nike Walmart Apple Nestle who in
the past 15 years or so have been
increasingly concerned about the issues
of forced labor and trafficking in their
supply chains around the world the
International Labor Organization
estimates about 21 million victims of
forced labor in the world today and most
of that forced labor does take place in
the private economy so in the supply
chains of companies like those that I
mentioned and so over the past 15 years
or so those companies have launched a
whole bunch of initiatives ranging from
different types of auditing to data
analytics
to multi-stakeholder initiatives
certifications like Fairtrade just a
whole spate of activity to try to
address the issue of forced labour and
their supply chain and what I'm looking
at in the book is the effectiveness of
those types of initiatives okay are they
actually working to trigger change on
the ground to actually address you know
the prevalence of forced labour within
these chains or are they in some ways
potentially driving the problem deeper
into the shadows of the global economy
and so I'm looking at this question of
effectiveness I'm looking at the
question of how are the private
initiatives that companies are launching
interacting with the public ones that
states are taking do things like
regulation labor inspection are they
complementing each other are the
corporate initiatives supplementing and
strengthening the public regulatory
initiatives or is there a trade-off
going on where the private ones are
taking a sort of greater role in the
governance fear and the public ones are
becoming less rigorous and potentially
have less teeth so those are the types
of things I'm getting at okay
and what led you to be interested in
this obviously difficult topic yeah
that's a good question in some ways it
goes back quite a ways for me when I was
an undergraduate in Washington State
there was a real problem going on with
prison labor so that was in the late you
know early 2000s there was a lot of
companies using prison labor as a
alternative to sort of outsourcing
overseas so there were reports of
companies like Boeing Starbucks Nike
Victoria's Secret usually through you
know their suppliers or subsidiaries but
setting up shop in prisons and and using
prisoners as a labor force instead of
you know free workers on the outside and
so I became interested at that time in
the community that I was living there
was a lot of concern about this and
there was you know the question of is
does this violate prisoners Human Rights
you have people who are
usually in prison in the US for poverty
related crimes unable to find jobs in
many cases then being made to work in
prison usually with very little pay and
without a real ability to to refuse that
work and so I became interested in that
less than the human rights elements of
it and more in the kind of political
economic role that it was playing in the
US economy what were companies getting
out of this in terms of it but mostly
what was the government getting out of
it you know what what was the government
gaining by opening up their prisons to
industry and so I just became interested
in that relationship between private
companies and the private economy and
forms of labor that are non-standard
that we tend to think of as being more
antiquated prison labor of course goes
very very far back in the history of US
capitalism and emerged in the sort of
aftermath of slavery and it was an
exception to the abolition of slavery so
it's a form of involuntary servitude so
my interest really goes back to that
that point of these things that we tend
to think of as antiquated relations why
do they emerge why are they so resilient
in the global economy and why haven't
the forces of modernity and the kind of
modern corporation eradicated these
forms of forced labor and why did some
companies seem to make use of them as an
alternative to a public labor force okay
I think many people would be somewhat
surprised to know that modern-day
slavery is happening as a part of
corporate America so I'm I'm imagining
that this is going on in countries where
corporations do business when they farm
at work overseas
so can you let's talk specifics give us
a couple of examples of things that you
know about that are currently going on
sure yeah I mean forced labor takes a
number of different forms it has been
documented in almost every country in
the world
so it's not exclusively a problem that
that's confined to the global South
though as you're saying a lot of it does
take place in in the in the global south
just to give a few examples of what this
kind of looks like The Guardian is a
uk-based newspaper recently did a
six-month undercover investigation of
the shrimp industry in Thailand which
was a real shock I think to a lot of
Americans because that investigation
uncovered that forced labor human
trafficking slavery were rampant in an
industry that supplies to the big
retailers you know in the u.s. in the UK
and Europe like Costco and Tesco and
what was happening there was that people
were being recruited usually migrant
workers from the neighboring countries
like Burma into the Thai fishing
industry and the workers were paying the
recruiters these third-party agents a
fee to find them a job in in the Thai
shrimp industry and so they were paying
this fee and then they were essentially
being sold off to boat captains where
they were at sea they were in you know
you know kind of hidden parts of the
economy they're there at sea there's not
a lot of surveillance no one's really
checking and there were rampant abuses
that ranged from torture to manipulation
of debt and wages all sorts of practices
that were classified as slavery so
that's one way that this can manifest
another type of example in you know in a
more manufacturing industry would be
Apple has recently taken a really
important step in banning what they
called involuntary servitude and their
supply chain so what they discovered
over the past year so was that in some
of their supplier factories like Foxconn
Pegatron in China a similar dynamic was
happening with recruiters going to find
workers who really needed work workers
who were pretty vulnerable often
migrants who didn't have any real
opportunities to work where they were
living
and so then they'd pay this the the
workers would pay a fee to the recruiter
they'd end up in the supplier factory
already very much in debt so the fee
might be a month's wages and then that
debt was used to impose very difficult
working conditions sometimes involuntary
overtime a lot of the dynamics we
associate with forced labor and so what
Apple did to their credit I think is
that they said you know workers can't be
made to pay those fees actually the
supplier firm needs to pay those fees to
the recruiter and even though ultimately
that meant Apple itself will be you know
having to cost that into their business
model they were willing to do that so
they've refunded four million dollars
recently to workers but a lot of
companies you know that's a practice
that happens pretty endemically within a
lot of industries and very few companies
have taken that kind of leading role
that Apple has taken to address it in
the way that they have okay in in
working on the book how are you doing
the research for it I would imagine in a
variety of ways are you talking to
actually actual people in companies
where things like this happen yeah
that's a great question firstly for as
you can well imagine is an extremely
difficult topic to research it's illegal
in almost every country in the world and
for good reasons you know companies and
governments are very hesitant to give
researchers access to their workers and
supply chains so one of the things I've
been working on over the past couple of
years is an initiative with the British
Academy looking at methods for forced
labor research so that's been bringing
together a number of us who are working
on social scientific research on forced
labor to talk about how we can
strengthen the methods at the moment
there's no country level data on forced
labor that's reliable there's there's
some very good case studies of forced
labor by sector so that have looked at
forced labor in the electronics industry
or in the garment industry or in a
particular country and what I've done in
my book is use that sector level data as
a sort of starting point to
understanding the dye
Amyx and the patterns of how some of
this is actually playing out but what
I've done in my book is I've I have
about three different strategies of
research that I've been carrying out
over the past few years so one is that
I've looked at sector level data on
forced labor I've done some studies of
forced labor in the UK in the cannabis
food and construction industries and
that's given me a really good sense of
the patterns of how these practices
manifest but also some of what companies
are doing to address them I've also
taken a look at audit firm data so
that's the data that audit firms are
collecting they're the ones who are kind
of going in and being the boots on the
ground in terms of conducting these
inspections of factories mining sites
the like and so they have a lot of
knowledge of how these practices have
evolved over time whether we're seeing
increases or decreases in different
sectors etc so I've used some of that to
gain insights about whether you know how
how practices are evolving and the last
thing that I've done is I've interviewed
a lot of people with first-hand
knowledge of the corporate social
responsibility initiatives and their
effectiveness
so that ranges from industry
representatives to auditors to people
involved with multi-stakeholder
initiatives really just a range of
different people I've conducted about a
hundred interviews on these questions to
try to get the best knowledge that's
available about whether these
initiatives are effective under what
circumstances they're effective and what
the gaps are in terms of further work
that needs to be done
okay so what what are the gaps in terms
of laws that are on the books at this
point I mean how are these people
falling through the cracks so to speak
mmm-hmm
I mean that that's a very good question
I think what we're seeing you mentioned
law in the books I think one of the
things we're seeing is that there's
actually a very good laws on the books
of a lot of countries and that the
problem is coming
one of the main problems is coming in
terms of enforcement of those laws so in
a lot of countries labor inspectorate's
have been cut the budget for labor
inspection has been reduced and so you
have real challenges in terms of
governments actually monitoring and
enforcing their own laws and in the wake
of that private the private sector has
really taken on a greater role but what
we're seeing is that some of those
initiatives like auditing don't
necessarily work as well as the public
sector initiatives to inspect factories
and so there are a number of challenges
that come up in relation to the private
sector having really taken on board the
issue of forced labor trafficking and
slavery but not necessarily pursuing the
types of initiatives and policies that
that seem to address the root causes of
these problems on the ground so what
what do you suggest to help fix the
problem
what do you think would work I think
that that's a very big yes I know and
I'm I know I'm putting you on the spot
but you know what are your ideas yeah I
think that what we need to start looking
at is we need to start looking closely
at the root causes of the problems
within business models so there's been a
real attention to the symptoms of the
problems of forced labor addressing you
know the worst exploitation Xand really
you know trying to break those people
out of slavery type situations and
that's been really important work that
NGOs and others have conducted but what
we need to start looking much more
closely at are the root causes of why
these types of exploitation are thriving
in the first place and that gets into
questions around things like
subcontracting the relationship between
the big brands and the suppliers and
their supply chain it gets at questions
around the price of goods you know
there's been a lot of pressure going on
to produce goods more and more cheaply
and sell them more and more cheaply and
that can create some real risks around
labor standards because it's very
difficult to produce goods
quickly cheaply on-time deliver them to
the retailer and do it in a way that
honors good labor practice all right so
you've seen on the one hand a rising
demand for sub minimum wage labor which
can sometimes take the form of forced
labor and supply chains and on the other
hand a burgeoning supply of people who
don't have decent work who are entering
into very vulnerable risky types of jobs
so you need to be able to combat both of
those sides of the root causes the
supply and the demand issues around
forced labor and supply chains okay
ultimately you know what are you hoping
people will take away from your book
that's another good question I guess I'm
hoping that people will take take away
the idea that these are systemic issues
there's been a lot of attention on you
know different sectors so the
effectiveness say of Fairtrade on coffee
growers in Guatemala or the these types
of you know can we really look at
effectiveness on this micro scale and
combat these issues on a micro scale and
part of what I think I'm trying to get
at in in the book and trying to
understand in the book is whether that's
effective or whether we need to be
taking a much more systemic look at
these problems as problems that are
fundamentally rooted in how the global
economy itself is set up and organized
and run and governed and so I think that
reframing forced labor and trafficking
and slavery as global economic problems
that are really deeply rooted in the
broader structures of the global economy
things like inequality things like the
power of companies via via governments
etc is what I'm really hoping to to to
understand and to raise questions about
in the book okay very good thank you so
much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work thank you for
having me for more information about
Professor LeBaron and her research
please visit our website at macmillan
report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale